hello there reject nation my name is
Greg my name is John we're gonna watch
from the warp zone one of the best
sketch channels on YouTube
spider-man reacts to the Disney Sony
breakup this is a no you bit me you
you're out of the room right now this is
a top of warrants here video request
from a man named Pete Dunn otherwise
known as Peter Dolan I thought like Oh
ma'am this is kind of old news that
apparently this video came out
mid-october there must be some relevancy
or they cover the reunion I don't know
oh let's watch it I love these guys
sketches they're hysterical a satirical
stuff well boys we did the Avengers
finally beat avatar the best hey you
guys when I joined the Avengers no way
you're just a stupid Netflix show and we
hate you yeah but in some cases the
Netflix shows her arguably higher
quality than the movies discoveries we
can't hear you over the sound of you
being unceremoniously canceled then
replaced by a bunch of Disney Plus shows
us that you never even existed with the
amount of your great NPD you can be
whatever you want
well then frankly I'm not doing so hot
this whole Sony Disney spider-man
breakup Fiasco is really throwing me for
a loop
I mean first I was an Avenger and then I
was a new Iron Man and now I'm legally
neither and actually a terrible oh no I
mean when I agreed to make I know they
barely broke 700 million the box office
[Laughter]
but the trade records oh man maybe you
can make your not just Tony's narc
sidekick even after he's dead I mean
wouldn't you like to have a villain
whose origin or motivations are actually
tied to your character and not just
another guy screwed over by Tony Stark
yeah yeah that would be kind of nice and
if you're not spending like 80% of your
screen time with people from the MCU you
can finally start developing your
supporting cast of pleasant but shallow
facts and leaves a beloved compo
characters into well-rounded
three-dimensional characters yeah I
guess Ned really did just kind of drop
off the face of the earth in that last
movie besides Disney Stallone's on your
comic TV and most importantly
merchandising rights so you'll still be
around in all the ways that matter to
our bottom line and you're still getting
your own ride at Disneyland and it's
right next to the Avengers right so uh I
don't like you're still an Avenger
that's a better deal that we're giving
Hawkeye if you ask me things are looking
pretty good in the old Spidey verse yeah
yeah you know what things really aren't
that bad no no I know what you're doing
you're doing that whole fancy smancy
Hollywood talk to make everything sound
like it's good but really you just want
me to do whatever you say
well I'm sorry mr. Richards but I've
seen the online reaction I've looked at
the petitions that I've read the blog
posts I know what the people want and
they want me back in the MCU and I'm not
leaving here until you patch things up
with Sony and make me an Avenger again
Wow spider-man the passion you displayed
here today has really moved me really
yes so much so that I'm gonna get on the
horn with the head of Sony Pictures and
set this whole thing right that's
amazing when about six months ago we
planned this little charade Oh Spidey my
naive little cash cow there never was a
break us we've had your release they
locked with some reasons before
comic-con
everything that's happened has just in
an elaborate puppet show put on by our
marketing
so many questions I guess the most
pressing why to keep the spider brand in
the spotlight b/c there was some concern
internally with all the new MCU movies
and Disney Plus shows in the pipeline
that inspired members get lost in the
shuffle so we devised a plan that would
keep spider-man in the headlines for
months without spending a single cent on
marketing really it was a stroke of pure
genius people really mad not mad
invested we renew that if you take
something people love away from then
it'll be the name it's obvious what we
learned is that and then get back to
people after enough public outcry people
feel as though they somehow contributed
to what they see as a victory which
increases their personal investment
after we practically assured a record
number of buffs we firmly planted in
theater seats encore III opens very
tricky kind of sneaky what if we take a
step further control the narrative from
beginning to end
so we had a little chat with Sony came
with the idea that they pretend to stop
sharing the spider-man movie rest of us
there'd be a breakdown during contract
negotiations deafening silence during
d23 finally peace was made Spiderman was
back where he belongs in the MCU we
created the ultimate soap opera and the
entire world was our middle-aged emotion
unfulfilled housewife how is that guy
follicle everybody wins so many wins
because they finally beat the spider-man
tonight viewers always wanted you
because you remain one of pop culture's
most beloved characters we win because
we make boatloads of money
audiences win because they feel like
they matter but most importantly we win
because we make boatloads of money yeah
no it won't work people are too smart
we'll see right through I think we both
know that's not true
I mean we somehow convince people that
Bruce Banner reconciling with a halt by
taking an off-screen gamma ray bath was
a satisfying conclusion whose floor film
character
if I expose you first
Oh Spidey boobie if you keep your mouth
shut
another specialist car tomorrow you will
make millions of your adoring fans happy
but if you tell the truth you're gonna
make people upset and things that make
people upset don't make money things
that don't make money don't get me do
you see where I'm going this don't tell
them it's okay Rorschach
you say oh hey glad you're a spy and be
sure to eat something okay look a little
skinny jean equal ballet thank you bye
do you need to start the search for a
live action Miles Morales I have a
feeling Gary
I liken this to like when Jay Roach or
Paul fake you know decides to make some
or Adam a cake decides to make some like
you know a political relevant biopic oh
yeah this seems like it had more of a
perspective and a stance wanting to get
a commentary out there active conspiracy
theory that it was about may get some
like parody sketch normally would I get
from warp zone
yeah these spoofs or whatever they
seemed like they wanted to go out there
really elaborate on a point that could
theoretically lead to a genuine
conspiracy this is something that a lot
of us have pondered if this is because
it's all I it was all evident that it
was very public negotiation especially
the way it concluded I mean I haven't
saw Bob Iger ago on Kimmel and this
Richard character seems to be a cross
between Kevin Feige
and Bob Iger sort of spliced into one
Bob Iger did talk about on Kimmel he's
like yeah Tom Holland did talk to us I
made the call to the president of Sony
hashed it out with them and then we
solved it by her talked about it's like
he was never involved in the talks until
Tom Holland game was like alright I'll
talk to the president of Sony and we
could work something out as this was
going on we were all thinking a lot of
us not all of us but a lot of us were
thinking of the James gun situation like
what they were talking about here it's
true what is talked about in this warp
zone sketch there's now even even higher
investment and now more of us are gonna
want to see this spider-man 3 and how
that's gonna unfold this I know I am I'm
gonna want to see like what are they
gonna do something different or they're
gonna try to end this would Tom Holland
so you can solely belong to Sony then it
makes me wonder about the post credit
scene or the mid-credits scene
spider-man far from home because that
ends in such a way where you need a part
three within the MCU specifically in
order to properly tell that tale I mean
everything they broke down here that
that idea rien gauging and making an
even stronger personal investment I
think I believe this you know we'll
never know for sure but it seems likely
yeah it definitely seems plausible and
it seems like the kind of dastardly sort
of money-grubbing scheme that probably
even if it didn't happen with this movie
I have to imagine that this kind of
thing happens has
happened it's interesting because yeah
the fan interaction with films and film
makers is so different now and is so
much more galvanized and intense that I
can very much imagine studios now
beginning to project like how are people
gonna respond how can we harness their
emotions to you know bring them back to
the theater and so yeah I don't know I
mean I can see how the negotiation could
have been genuine and broken down or the
same time it does seem like an odd
arrangement because like it's such a
huge tentpole thing they already had to
work out such a I don't know there's
something about it that seemed like it
never wasn't gonna get fixed because of
that maybe it does lend an element of
plausibility to this because I never
believe that it's like oh they're not
gonna bring him back like it just didn't
ever seem plausible in terms of public
negotiation there's so much that really
wasn't being said to us and so much just
kept happening at a rapid pace the
information linking to Kevin Feige and
Tom Holland both doing those those talks
on camera I forgot what newspaper it was
for but saying you know Kevin Feige
especially saying like I feel grateful
you know I knew what's it gonna be
forever and Tom Holland being like you
know we do have big plans trust Sony and
then Tom Cohen coping to Disney talking
to them and then suddenly the news
wrapping all arounds and they have a
release date locked not just we got a
contract we're gonna do be doing this
they got a release date locked for the
next spider-man film yeah it seemed it
does seem like it was all part of the
plan
I appreciate warm Suns approach to doing
this at first there's a little bit of
readjustment for me on the sketch like
wait spider-man
is not this is not Tom Holland this is
just spider-man is the property here
that has come to life yeah it's like
Roger Rabbit in a way but its spite of a
real life spider-man oh surprise this is
gonna tense one of those conspiracy
theory political movies that like I said
the comedy directors eventually end up
directing but when I blast you when I
was watching this it oddly made me start
to wonder like okay who is in these
public negotiations feeding us this
information negotiations of that scale
they have control over who gets what
information disseminated where and how
made me think then of like okay who's
leaking this information to us how
comprehensive visit how complete how
accurate yeah but either way we're gonna
get spider-man 3 in July 2021 well as
much of a conspiracy as it might be it
worked on me and I'm just happy
spider-man's back aren't we all
guys you can subscribe to warp zone do
you think they lied to the public about
all this just to manipulate our hearts
and our commitment comment below you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and Pete
Don thanks for sending this video our
way buddy Pete just ran a marathon
actually he didn't get it completed
though or a movie made about it he huh
Britney runs a marathon Pete Don runs a
marathon movie references it's what we
do yes yes thank you you're welcome
he ran a marathon but he didn't get it
completed though he only got to mile 15
and then they had to call him a medic Oh
some might say hey 15 miles is pretty
good actually that's still an impressive
amount of miles to run at a consistent
pace and if you got a prematurely leave
a marathon you know in an ambulance is
probably the most justifiable way but
you know what else I would say to you
you bitched out you should have just
kept running and puking along the way
you should have just gone until fainting
had occurred crawl if you have to scrape
you know do that horror movie thing
where your fingernails come up but don't
give up you know don't listen to your
body your body doesn't know as much as
your mind your mom struggled to push you
out of her a crotchety crotch yeah she
didn't call an ambulance
46 years ago what are you in your
mid-50s now Pete and it could have been
stronger anyway but thank you so much
for being a part of our patreon page and
Sue's I've never read 15 miles in my
life
I've got eleven and a half and I puke
nine times so huh you got one up on me